there is no job in the world where you
can be so wrong so consistently and keep
your job more than an economist what am
i talking about going into q1 economists
forecasters bankers investors and tons
and tons of talking pundits around the
world they all put out these forecasts
and they say we believe the gdp growth
number is going to be x now of course
when they report the number they take
the growth in a single quarter and they
annualize it so for example if gdp grows
one percent in a quarter they say hey we
are on a four percent annualized gdp
growth trajectory and that's how they
report these numbers going into the q1
gdp numbers it was expected it was
forecasted by all these geniuses that
gdp was going to grow one percent
annualized well we got the numbers
yesterday and guess what happened fellas
the gdp growth was negative 1.4 percent
annualized that is a 240 basis point
swing in the wrong direction
not only were they off by 240 basis
points which literally just means you're
incompetent at your job but to put salt
in the wound they thought the economy
was going to grow and the economy
contracted you couldn't be more wrong it
couldn't be more black and white they
literally thought things were going well
and instead things are not going well
now of course why is this happening well
if you ask yourself that question you
immediately jump to the idea that the
party is over what do i mean if you go
back to march of 2020 what you find is
that there was a liquidity crisis due to
the fact that the government ordered
every citizen to go sit at home
because of the pandemic
and when that happened there was
short-term pain 6.6 million people a
week were claiming first-time
unemployment claims unemployment in
america skyrocketed over 10 percent
stocks fell 30 percent
we saw gold down about 15 percent and
bitcoin went down 50 in a single day it
was chaos and so naturally the federal
reserve central bankers and elected
officials all sat there and said we have
to do something we can't just sit by and
let the people suffer
so what did they do
they printed trillions of dollars and
they started throwing it everywhere they
literally were bailing out entire
industries like the airlines they were
going and sending out 1200 checks to
individuals they were manipulating
interest rates down to zero percent and
they were just handing out free money
they were extending pvp loans all over
the place and then just saying ah don't
worry you don't have to pay it back to
us
and so naturally they started a party
and they helped everybody get drunk on
free money the money was free the money
was cheap and if somebody hands you free
cheap money what do you do you start
spending it start buying things you
start investing it you start lending it
anything and everything you can do with
that money to gain any sentence of value
whether it's something for you to
consume or it's something for you to
grow the free cheap money gets put to
work and that's exactly what they wanted
they wanted to mitigate the short-term
pain they needed to drive the velocity
of money again and so they handed out
all this free cheap money now the
problem is if you do that for three
months six months nine months maybe even
12 months people don't really have time
to get used to it but if you do it for
two years
all of a sudden people start to say
themselves man i bet you they're gonna
keep giving me the free cheap money you
start to change behavior and that's
exactly what occurred we saw people
continue to act stupid and stupid and
stupid because they had free cheap money
now you can't blame them because they
had the money and the government kept
pumping more and more money into the
economy they kept interest rates
artificially low and so the party raged
on for literally 15 18 20 different
months
but back in november they realized hmm
this inflation thing that we've been
saying is transitory
b it's not going to be transitory maybe
we should stop using that word maybe
inflation is going to be higher than we
thought and maybe it's going to be
around for longer than we thought and so
naturally they started to talk tough
they didn't do anything but they started
to talk about ah we're gonna have to
taper oh we're gonna have to raise
interest rates and now the sophisticated
investor said oh that's a different talk
truck than i've been hearing and so they
went ahead and they stopped investing in
various markets they started to sell
their risk assets and move into more
value or reserve type assets and so
naturally if all of a sudden somebody
stops investing and then a lot more
people stop investing in certain assets
the price begins to fall and that's what
we saw in november both in the crypto
market and also in the stock market is
the prices began to fall because the
sophisticated investors realized the
environment is going to change the party
is over the punch bowl is going to get
taken away and we are going to have to
go back to a world where the government
and the central bank is not propping up
the market now as those prices have been
falling guess what also is falling
if i don't have money to go and make
investments because i'm worried that
capital is going to get more expensive
and is not going to be handed out so
freely i probably am also not going to
buy as many things either so the same
way that investments went up as did the
price of consumable goods in the good
times in the bad times i stopped
allocating as much money to investments
and i also stopped buying as many goods
or services as well and so naturally
that's where we get this contraction of
the u.s economy now for our recession to
occur well that's two quarters of
negative gdp growth we got it back in
2020 something tells me that it's not
going to turn around here and so my
guess is that when by the time we get
the q2 data we will be officially in a
recession now how the hell can we go
from a recession
to all-time high stock prices to
all-time high inflation numbers or
40-year highs and then back into a
recession all in two years well that's
because the market is manipulated all
you're watching is central banks around
the world what are they doing they
simply are jumping in the game and
they're saying every time something
happens good times we must intervene bad
times we must intervene good times we
must intervene bad times we must
intervene the volatility gets more and
more extreme
what we need in the world is free
markets we do not need people
intervening in the market let the free
market take control if they were to
allow to do that
there may be short-term pain but we
would get on a long-term record where we
would be on a path to a more sustainable
less volatile economy that's not going
to happen and so naturally we got that
1.4 annualized contraction in the
economy all of a sudden people are
waking up but it's a weird weird world
if you expect plus one percent you get
negative 1.4 percent and at the same
time all that's happening is very high
degrees of inflation at a 40-year high
what happens when the economy is
contracting and the inflation's high
well ladies and gentlemen here's what i
think is going to happen i think that
they are going to continue for the next
one or two rate hikes they're gonna keep
trying to do it they're gonna push us
further into a recession things can get
real nasty out there people are going to
panic there's going to be all sorts of
chaos and public pressure heading into
the midterm elections all of a sudden
the democratic party they're going to
tap central bankers on the shoulder apes
uncle jerome
cut it out we got to end this recession
we're going into election big dog
cut rates
get free money into the system and
probably by the end of q3 what we are
going to see is we are going to see the
federal reserve and elected officials
they're going to go back to party mode
they're going to flood the system with
free money they're going to go ahead and
start dropping interest rates and
they're going to realize that no matter
how much they're trying to taper they
are going to push the economy into a
massive recession and potentially a
depression which they're not going to
allow to happen and therefore they will
go right back to all of the easing
monetary and fiscal policy that they
previously were conducting so if that is
to occur big if but i believe it will if
that is to occur all you as an investor
have to do
just get out your diamond hands just
hold on because literally there's gonna
be lots of volatility ahead it's kind of
like when you're on a plane there's a
bunch of turbulence not much you can do
just hold on you get to the other side
of it that's my guess of what's gonna
happen over the next six to nine months
now if this is what happens it's going
to be absolutely fascinating to look
back in the history books to see
2020 recession then a stock all-time
high 2021 continuous stock all-time
highs 40-year high inflation 2022 bam
recession bam right back to stock
all-time highs these people have lost
their minds they only know how to
intervene in the market and they are
going to continue to do this because
their entire incentive system is simply
to address the short-term pain that
short-term pain
happens in both directions can't have
too high of inflation can't have too bad
of a recession but if you only can
manipulate interest rates and conduct
all sorts of undisciplined fiscal policy
then ladies and gentlemen you get what
we got which is high inflation and
recession same time double whammy call
it the economic poison pill because
we're all screwed hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time